les ha costado casi 40 años pero algunas
familias peruanas lograron recuperar los
restos de sus seres queridos víctimas de
la masacre de accomarca cuando en 1985
el ejército mató prácticamente a la
aldea entera tras acusarlos de
pertenecer al grupo terrorista sendero
luminoso con sus restos dentro de
pequeños ataúdes blancos' teófila ochoa
da el último adiós a su madre ya sus
cinco hermanos el dolor de tu corazón
jamás se va a borrar se va a doler si a
mi madre no me traería viva a mis
hermanos a ese puede curar pero no
porque hay un dolor por haber perdido
mis familiares sí que sé que he
encontrado sí sí que lo voy a enterrar
sí pero las heridas
nunca se va a borrar porque está acá
ella se salvó al salir corriendo al
campo pero la mayoría de los habitantes
de accomarca no corrieron la misma
suerte cuando los militares dirigidos
por el subteniente telmo hurtado
entraron en el pueblo el 14 de agosto de
1985 y asesinaron a sus habitantes
los 20 niños
ellos pensaron que los terroristas matan
ese tiempo
los niños niños niños también no nos
respetaban
hasta el 2002 la justicia peruana no
comenzó a investigar la matanza para
después condenar a una decena de
militares como autores mediatos o
materiales del crimen ahora las familias
de los fallecidos planean darle
sepultura el viernes en la aldea rodeada
de pinos y eucaliptos con la intención
de cerrar ese capítulo horrible de sus
vidas